you had a pretty numb in your life
your parents were professors you
have done a lot of sort of incredible
things that
many would say kind of like how the hell
are you going to get this done
is there advice you can give to young
people today
like high school college about
how to do how to live a similarly
non-linear crazy life and accomplish be
as successful as you have been
about whether it's just their career or
life in general the greatest
gifts i've been given have come from
pursuing curiosity
just trying to understand the thing
you're curious about and allowing
yourself to be curious about it and just
going with it and also pursuing things
that are like
deeply joyful for me
not what society wants but you just
personally just on your own you're happy
and that's something that in the times
when i strayed from that
my life has been harder right so
it's fundamentally what are we on earth
to do
you know to live and thrive and
so pursuing things that
are curious and satisfying and
interesting and joyful and allow me
to to grow so the
i made a number of choices to do things
that were more complicated and kind of
not not considered like so cool at the
time although now
it's cool to work on farms it wasn't
when i started my career in animal
agriculture
and it was like but just deeply
interesting to me
and i felt like there was just lots to
learn and so
that's been the the path for me is like
going for something that's like curious
and hard
and kind of sticking with it and being
open to it and
growing elements that give me joy
through that
so i also you know for people who are
starting out in their careers and want
to do something different too it's like
get out of your comfort go to a place
that you've got something to learn from
and let it teach you that and you'll
you'll get beat up like i got beat up by
that
experience like it was really hard you
know i laugh about now working
for insistently for tease me i mean
like and the funny experiences i had
there but it was hard i was lonely i
cried a lot it was stressful it was like
it was hard it was really hard
when you inside it you didn't know how
it's going to turn out you didn't know
it's going to
turn around like why didn't i get a job
doing something that all my friends were
doing and
it and and i didn't speak the language i
had to learn foreign language and
learn how to function and it like it was
very lonely and very challenging but
then
that's where my resilience started to
grow right so the things i learned there
ended up just being about resilience and
understanding
the language of subtlety and meaning so
that's something that's carried me
through my life but it was a curiosity
about cheese making and about like
just living in a village that was there
i'm like wouldn't it be amazing just
live in a really
rural village and you just went with it
and i just like this seems incredible
and
and have a place where you can you know
and these like the
the people seem interesting the food
seems good and let's just like try this
and see what i can learn
and that like putting yourself out of
your comfort zone
in a place where you have a chance to
learn and grow is
is the the secret because it's you grow
through discomfort
you know people think that you grow when
you get into this environment where
everything's like kind of
sailing along but like growth actually
comes through pain
you know it's like you you know growth
comes from being cut down and beat down
and having to re
regrow and double down and so that kind
of
that kind of opportunity you have to
seek it out you have to put yourself
in the line of fire a bit if the
situation sucks
it's a sign that you might be doing
something right in the sense that you're
on the path
at the end of which you'll be a better
person if you allow yourself to grow in
that way like as opposed to resisting it
just uh going along with the journey and
persevering
you